why'd you take my phone why'd you take
my phone everybody's got a question on
their mind
hey Sharkey you could ask I J welcome to
ask IJ first youtube comment we have see
bizzle t real 88 asking to see how would
you react if you have spent an extended
period of time without your iphone can't
hear you why'd you take my so much you
take my phone why'd you take my phone
let's just hope that never happens maybe
comment award goes to miss Jamie :
asking me if I'd rather eat all of my
hair or like a golden retriever why
would you even say those things Twitter
question are you an app addicts I'm
going to assume that you mean iPhone
apps so in that case yes aiya that was
only the first page of the top
hi I just and I wanted to ask a question
next to you on a commercial on
television yes that was me I couldn't
know who it was but some thing it was
for mozi comm they do online storage
backup and while most crashes don't
involve a burning appliance how do you
protect your digital photos music and
financial documents anybody else seen
those commercials on TV if you have you
come for the last video response have a
continuance of the girl trying to sing
my theme song from the beginning of the
video so cute hey hey oh yeah I want you
to do it come here that's it fresca a
number of shoots live you guys know what
to do add comments below add a video
response and ask me questions on Twitter
but next week I'm gonna have a special
segment of ask IJ where you can ask me a
question on Facebook that's right to
Facebook now has their new Facebook
pages so you can become a friend of me
on Facebook over at facebook.com slash
iJustine and ask me questions in the
discussion board and well that's it I'll
see you guys on next episode I gotta go
edit this so I can launch it okay